right
this is the world's most powerful Rocket
taking off
and this is it exploding shortly after
years of development spacex's Starship
and its super heavy Rockets with its 33
Raptor engines finally got Airborne in
April for a short while at least now
while SpaceX has launched hundreds of
spaceships it's Starship that the
company hopes will become a rapidly
reusable Gateway into space but while it
may have taken years to get even to this
point it's actually just the very
beginning of starship's long road to
carry humans to another planet so what's
the journey ahead for Starship and what
will it take to get there
SpaceX say the idea behind Starship and
the super heavy is to be the first fully
reusable space transportation system
where both the spaceship and the rocket
powering it can be used over and over
again one of the most prominent missions
for Starship will be to carry astronauts
from a spacecraft orbiting the moon down
to the lunar surface and back as part of
NASA's Artemis 3 moon landing missions I
caught up with wsj's space reporter
Micah maidenberg NASA awarded a nearly
three billion dollar contract for the
Artemis 3 moon landing that's currently
scheduled for you know sometime in 2025
2025 is coming up pretty quickly for
space actions it's a very high profile
and intense objective that they have to
reach SpaceX is also planning on using
Starship to carry cargo into space
whether that be the company's starlink
satellites or fuel for other starships
and SpaceX CEO Elon Musk has also said
that one day he hopes to use Starship
for a mission to Mars but building
something this complex that's fully
reusable isn't exactly easy as musk said
at wsj's CEO Council in 2021 man
Starship is a hard hard hard project
um it is so preposterously difficult
that there are times where I wonder
whether we can actually do this
so what did we learn from the launch
well while there have been some tests of
Starship before this is the first time
it's been powered by the massive super
heavy rocket system and the company
wasn't exactly sure how successful the
launch would be if we lift off and clear
the pad we're calling that a win
things seem to be going well for the
first few minutes
although it appeared that some of the
Raptor engines were out the super heavy
rocket also failed to separate from
Starship and then
however the launch will have left the
company with a trove of data you know
one of the main goals of this fight was
simply to get information the way SpaceX
historically is operated is when it
learns something it uses that to try to
quickly make changes improvements to to
iterate so what's it going to take to
get Starship from this
to this well SpaceX will need a lot more
test flights as NASA's Moon Mission
could be as soon as two years away Gwen
Shotwell this big company is long-time
president said a couple months ago at a
conference she wants to fly a lot of
flights with Starship starting with the
company's own star links satellites
because they need to figure out what
this vehicle what this machine can do
one thing that's almost certain is that
NASA will be watching those flight tests
closely the agency has said they're not
going to use Starship to carry humans
until they've been successful tests and
that SpaceX will conduct an uncrewed
demonstration to the Moon prior to the
Artemis missions so in a way right now
then one of the big next steps for the
Artemis program is for SpaceX to show
that it can operate Starship the way
it's like laid out to do so while the
launch might have been one giant leap
for Starship it's just one small step
for SpaceX
[Music]